islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
hello welcome guys hope you guys want to
shut up we are here with you sean
oh it's quick i'm very [ __ ] fast it's
just i've spawned like that why are you
going fast too fast
okay guys hope you guys are well
inshallah welcome back to my channel why
are you dressed like a christmas tree
because i am one dr berg do you know dr
berg
dr berg
not berg oh no bad
bad man
leo wayne's manager
he's someone that i watch a lot i think
you subscribe to him i think you don't
know him but those who know know as well
he is very good but when it comes to
like health but he goes in depth yeah
he's a reliable yes he's very reliable
yeah he's got big followers
45 million years in this field the thing
is this though yeah he done a video
about ramadan and he was like why are
people in the middle east have the
lowest rates of cancer
yeah yeah and i found interesting wow so
i watched it and well he's he's actually
conducted a research a study yeah he's
done like basically i don't know if he's
a study but he's found out that the
lowest rates of p people have cancer in
the it's in the middle east that's
amazing so then he looked into okay for
example the diets
they don't drink alcohol yeah they don't
smoke yeah and it's not saying
typically yeah typically they don't
smoke and he one of the factors he
mentioned was fasting
yeah they fast okay so i was like
obviously the the doctors now recommend
that you first to take two days a week
exactly yeah the process monday and
thursday anyway yes now he mentions
ramadan now this is very interesting a
lot of times a lot of people would
expect the video to be like that's the
miracle of allah subhanallah yeah
exactly what did he say that like okay
fasting in ramadan so would you use that
as a miracle and be like that's why
islam is true because now bro you know
what atheists love pointing this out and
and i rate them for that they have
something called god of the gaps which
means anything that science allegedly
can't explain
religious people just shunt religion
into it yeah or if something happens to
work maybe 10 times it won't work but it
works once you say yeah god did it yeah
but i mean yeah we shouldn't fall into
those traps
yeah and and make it seem like any time
something happens yeah god did it it
makes us too desperate look allah has
put means in place okay the whole system
i don't i don't know everything is a
miracle i don't need to see allah's name
written on a fish or somewhere to say
that's a miracle it's everywhere you get
it makes us look desperate like you've
got nothing else to turn to but a fish
that has
on it yeah let me just be real so we
have many more miracles
allah's name on it on the fish yeah no
of course exactly of course but the
point here is this year
yes that's good and it might be a wisdom
a hikmah that that might be the case
maybe but the thing that we need to
understand is the following guys ramadan
even if ramadan argument's sake was bad
for your health argument's sake yeah
it's still from allah yes
so the reason i'm doing this video is i
appreciate dr burke he's very good he
has the muslim people that message him
you know the viewers etc i'm one of
those as well but the thing is well
what's one thing's important to mention
you say even if ramadan was bad for us
even if ramadan seemed bad for us yes
because science hadn't caught up with
his understanding but then later on we
would realize that ultimately it was
good for exactly you cannot use we don't
want to use signs of the yardstick so
anybody that yeah that comes and uses
says that he asks if this was the quran
you're about to get slapped up
or even proof for islam it's not
necessarily exactly because some people
come and say oh this says this in sight
science recently found out this this
yeah and i'm like well you're so dumb
it's one answer science is not a united
states yeah they don't use this science
recently they're coming and denying the
whole big bang there's shifts happening
in the scientific field yeah and it's
happening in the past as well so the
point is this called paradigm shifts
right yeah
yeah thank you
but the point is this guys yeah allah
subhanahu was told us the faster ramadan
that's it when somebody comes and says
why did you guys pass him down oh but dr
berg said that it's good for health low
rates of cancer
don't see that oh no no you shouldn't
because you know why we very simply
why'd you fast in ramadan
okay
why'd you wear the hijab because allah
told you to why'd you wake up fajr
because allah told me to
all of these things is because allah and
sisters it's as simple as that stop you
can see
maybe the wisdom is that dr buck said so
maybe that's the question
because dr buck said yeah so what does
that mean it means dr buck is the main
guy in it
one second cut this here
yeah anyways so the point is that
brothers and sisters inshallah what was
the point again
i'm joking brother sisters i have to
help you guys benefit from that and it's
very important for us to understand
anything that you deem to be a miracle
do not run with it it can be something
that's debunked you never know he might
find a new study and say oh cancer rates
have gone up even though they're faster
we're going to say now oh
allah told us to do something that is
not right no we do what we do because
allah told us to do science science is
actually based on
the like this there's two things number
one they did it's called the um
[Music]
they did a study
there are two words
no it's
you know when you've done a scientific
experiment okay and then you repeat it
again yes um it was on crash course and
they said
i think about 50
or or it was a low percentage they were
able to replicate the same results
so they weren't able to verify
the same results even when it comes to
peer review journals sometimes there's a
lot of bias about who's funding the
research
where it's coming from
um so that's another issue about science
also um and thirdly how you interpret
the data yeah
if you've got um you know a certain
correlation they actually did again it
was on crash course and they said look
if you take certain uh data different
scientists will interpret it differently
yes so there's names for it but the
names of my headset
you can't just rely on science because
science is constantly changing yes and
there's a man who's here
okay brother sisters until next time
hope you enjoyed that video i'll see you
later